hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger salut patrick oui et
donc pas du public
ça pue la trique je vous le dis il va y
avoir un geyser de pétrole
la nullité on a ça de relancer les sept
dans viva et au t1 bis toujours en
musique plus triste que les vagues de
julien courbet plus désolant que ceux de
christophe carrière le flashmob de la
caisse d'assurance maladie de haute
garonne
mais jean-louis de la compta et sa
guitare qu'il à jour et un son fils de 8
ans pau faire rockstar vas-y jean-louis
le flash mob de la cpam de l'émotion
avec la scène de l'embrouillé katia
d'accueil sur du nougaro
[Musique]
cb